[Music]
you
[Applause]
but this talk actually came from was I
was at a conference about a month ago
maybe two months ago now and the the
idea of the talk was a number of
advanced concepts and continuous
deployment is something we're doing at
absolute how many people are familiar
with continues to point it out so you
heard that story
okay so we're basically deploying our
site which is much more of a monolithic
out micro services out but we're
deploying that about 40 to 50 times per
day and we've distributed that across
for engineering to so one of the
advanced topics that I was talking about
was how do we do that how do you get
that many people deploying in a single
day and what is release management look
like so tonight is basically one piece
of that talk when when the quarter about
talking and trying to do it so when you
do a lot of deployment
we've got this process you couldn't do
very very rapidly and hire people and on
board them the first thing you need to
do is figure out how to unboard them
into that process you're interviewing
software so you're testing essentially
and learning how well how much they know
about me really you're going to trust
that they understand that what we need
to teach very very early in our in our
lifecycle for engineers is how to go
through the clinton process because the
worst thing you can do is a bunch of
code over number of weeks and then and
then be shy about deploying it so the
first thing you want to is you can play
code which means we give you a very
simple simple exercise we have one of
your pages on our site because we're a
tech company in its 2014 where
everybody's faces on the on the about
page so the exercise is check out the
code base get your VM running
understand where the templates are and
get it I get this get your own image in
there that go through all the tests and
learn how to go through the
play the process and so I want to talk
about what the deployment process
actually looks like because it's not
something you would have gone out and
planned on your own this is something
we've done over four years and some of
the stuff is surprisingly close but a
number of things are finesse and
subtleties that we've added over time so
I just want to mention like you know why
would you want to do deployments so
frequently we do continuous employment
particularly so that we can get code
from developers hands or mine into
production very very rapidly I find a
big switch between developing code in
dev environment where you've got test
data or even being a stage in market
where you're trying to simulate data
versus what actually happens in
production we have live users and live
data and data that's existed or product
that's been around for nine years of
iteration which despite all of our best
attempts we've never been able to sing
like that properly that we always find
some kind of surprise when we go from
dev to stage to production so it looks a
bit different app deploys throughout the
day we have two different kinds of
deploys now a full applicant which is
all of our code and then convicted
poised which are a couple of config
files but they lived in the codebase but
we can deploy them we rapidly because
they're much more lightweight
we're not fewer tests against them so AB
deploys are like big bits of new code
new one launch features that are gated
by can big flags it might be things
simple things like graphics or style
sheets or type teeny things like that in
some respects your your hire site
becomes a CMS if it
easy to play you don't have to go
through an IT department and then config
deploys are these flags that allow us to
turn on and off different parts of the
application so one good example of this
would be if we wanted to turn off search
for the entire site we have a flag that
turns off all the search so we take all
of the traffic off the searched here we
would kill the search box in the in the
UI and that would allow us to resolve an
issue with search if we actually have a
problem with that at that layer and
we've got thousands of these flags that
allows us to essentially operate the
site start engineering team when you
talk about DevOps for us that really
means bringing these years and the and
the operations team very very close
together so it's not the ops team really
decided you can use ready but we're all
working together on this so we talked
about this idea of like operating the
website we write code the employer and
then we maintain it in production and
think and we learn through how the
application works on their live traffic
have a write better code over time and
have responded issues that have made
more resilient applications so we
started coordinating our deploys in RFC
at some point we this is really starting
in 2010 we had about 22 engineers on the
team and we started using a one one
button deployed tool it's very very easy
with her application to deploy it
essentially with our sink and a few
other scripts but we said you know we
got to figure out how we know who is
actually the point at anytime during the
day and then you get the next question
which is who's the planning wet
mr. Danson it's another simple solution
again this is just people coming up with
like super super stupid easy solutions
just put everybody's name and delineator
with pipes instead of pipes and three of
us go at the same time this group will
have another one after that and that
worked pretty well and you'll see as I
get into this a little bit further at
some point you know when I put my name
in and John and Ross put their names and
sometimes you have collisions when you
have enough engineers so multiple people
moving the topic at the same time and I
get picked out of out of the queue so
come up with some solutions for that and
I'm going to point out that this is we
were sort of feedbacking on some of the
continuous deployment stuff that had
been going on at Flickr and I am to you
back in 2009 and that I knew to Nadine
Fitz if anybody's familiar with the work
that he's done and what he's written up
for that continuous deployment they had
a system where if you commit code and it
passes test it automatically starts the
pointing to production it goes through a
system in canary pools and health checks
to make sure that that's that stable and
then conducive way afterwards we wanted
to keep real people in the loop we
wanted to avoid the situation where my
tip would you know I commit something
and I
and go where - my lunch and walk out and
just assume that the tests are going to
are going to bill and save me or or
something else in there is gonna save me
so what are people to be involved at
once with us and then along with that I
said that we sort of stack people up
found over time that the optimal queue
size were batch size for us is setting
and we did that by just literally
analyzing our see logs for how quickly
people move to the queue and figuring
out that in larger batches at some point
there's so many people that you had too
much complexity to every deploy and if
that deploy goes wrong then you have a
lara longer period at which you're
trying to diagnose what went wrong and
solve that so we just came up we found
that the optimal number for us at the
time we're still using this as seven
that keeps the queue moving quickly but
limits generally limits complexity to
reasonable size it's like I said this is
all in IRC and I'm gonna apologize
because when I did these slides before
they were in a gigantic screen test so
I'm just gonna literally walk you
through what happens in IRC because I
think this is the part that we take for
granted all the time we basically say
like we do this in IRC and we've got one
button employees and that's it how all
this is coordinated is really kind of
interesting so in the beginning how many
people can not read this okay as much as
possible and I can barely read over here
so we started out and what happens is
you've got a boxing channel actually
called quick bot it is it is maintaining
sort of fluidity
he's normalizing communication and you
talk to the Bob when you want to join
you and the bot tells you when you're up
and what's going on with the question it
keeps things orderly when you don't have
this you have humans saying did your
stuff alright and somebody else says
cool man and you're like what do you
mean by cool mm-hmm so pushpots or
normalizes what's that yes a bit like a
traffic cops I also think about truckers
in some respects if we're at air traffic
control we have a very very short
communication so each of these people
are queued up and push bot says it's
actually your time to deploy so you're
going to get in and you're going to
commit your code to to master and then
you're going to go through the whole
deploy sequence so each of these people
music man in saying I've committed my
code is in I am ready to go so when
everybody else is ready to go
feel free to push us along to the next
step and after everybody in that that
deploy is checked in and pushpot says ok
everybody is ready to go
Adrian who's in the front of this queue
is designated the dryer driver this is
like the in the jury panel and being
selected in the first first position
anybody else said that happened to them
I had that I was I had to read off all
of our edits at the young it was kind of
a pain so Adrian is driving and he's
going to use our deploy tool which is
called the pointer this is honor this is
our github page if you want to use if
you want to find the planner and try
that out it's literally like a nifty
sort of UI front-end on top of a bunch
of shell scripts and other garbage that
you use there boy everybody has this to
deploy their code we just haven't
see why in front of it but this is sort
of water cooler we say for like the
status of deployment because you can see
everything that's going on here
these are all our it shows for each
environment that we're in we have a test
environment where the customer running
this environment is called princess
because everybody has an environment
well princess it's actually a
pre-production in that production so you
can see the state of what code is in in
each environment you can see the push
topic from IRC you can see the log of
all the things that have ever been
deployed and then these include gun logs
of the actual deploy the disks of the
code and dashboards get to dashboards
for monitoring this early build progress
so the QA tester running right now these
buttons would highlight and be active if
you could actually employ at least in
those environments at the time so there
they actually lock out when when you're
in some part of testing and it's so
distracting so next we've got another
bottle called got mine and Deb bot says
oK we've got the test started and then
Jenkins our building server comes in and
says alright we're starting to build for
QA and for princess so we actually
interesting thing here is instead of
deploying sequentially on these two
environments we deploy both at the same
time because closely what we found is
that the people test in QA first and
make sure everything is passed and then
they make sure that the tests and
everything your past and princess before
they actually go to production but we
just found that we could save a few
minutes by deploying both of these at
the same time for us so then we're five
minutes further down one here and that
box pipes back in those okay no princess
has been deployed and which bot says
your codes on Princess
so these two bots are talking to us
giving us a constant status of what's
going on throughout the thing and one of
the things to highlight here is that
cutter or IRC you see it work so because
bushbot keeps using the nicknames and
channel everybody who's in the ploy
keeps getting a notification on their on
their desktop saying thank you
here we are is where we are constantly
bringing you back into what's happening
so you don't get distracted this whole
process will take a series of minutes
right
so the Box keep you keep you apprised of
status it's said this basically but the
interesting thing here is we've also got
links going to the run log of the deploy
so if something actually goes wrong we
can go back to what you know what the
the build scripts output work and you
can see the dip so when we've had these
four people commit all their stuff now I
can see a link to the diff that includes
all the commits in one versus what the
last deploy was so I can see a entire
change stuff that's going out to
production and got lunch box talking to
each other at this point
Mike who's right here jumps in and says
hey Kevin is that for yours so at some
point Kevin and another channel has
issued a hold on that planet oh boy yes
okay so this dot join means I want to
get into another deploy queue in the
future the twist pod is going to put him
into another the pipe delineated things
with the master maximum batch size of 7
pushpots gonna maintain that for us so
push bug is the one who always maintains
the topic in this channel and maintains
the queue going through and then Kevin
sake here and Mike's talking back and so
not only do bots talk to us but humans
talk to each other
this is generally in in the push channel
general communication banter although
like we've got channels for that we
generally discourage it so this channel
is generally moderated for you know keep
the cross traffic to a minimum talk
about what's going on there because this
channel is like it's like air traffic
control like I said earlier like you
want the channel clear and understand so
that you can see when something comes up
and says hey something's wrong with the
production we should jump into that they
were not losing track of it by like so
at this point Gerard says no because
robots speak Spanish too
but basically what he's saying is the
code that is deployed I've checked it in
in a browser and my changes look good
I've done my ad hoc testing my stuff is
good instead of cool bro where else
okay so what what happened was I
mentioned it princess in QA got two
plays at the same time since this landed
first QA is way bill a little bit longer
we have success and we've got the
timestamp like a duration on here we
shoot for an SLA of test all of our
tests for QA all of our tests for
princess all of our
that's in production all of them are
expected to be under five minutes and
this is actually a failure here because
a little bit over five minutes but if
you're going to employ this frequently
throughout the day that means you have
to keep your tests really trim not flaky
and that we have thousands of them there
parallelized so we can do do this really
rapidly and we've got a team of people
who literally run our CI infrastructure
and make sure the tests are passing
we've got a huge dashboard of tester
asians over time and you can see that
creep up over time and fix it back down
but that's an entire role to keep this
process moving quickly to the test
results in CI so this this link goes to
our Hudson server and you can see all
the tests that have been running there
and look and the status of those if that
fails that's where you're gonna go to
figure out what actually failed so at
this point we're eight minutes in we've
got everything passing on QA and yeah
the QA failed es la overpass and QA and
everybody's gonna start checking in to
say that everything's cool to go further
here dead by the saying everyone has run
try recently so try is actually a pre
commit cluster that we use for testing
so what happens is because everybody is
committing to master all the time
if you want master to always be green to
have some way of validating before
you've done that that all of the tests
have passed before you commit
so our try suite is basically a way that
you can say take this patch that I'm
about to commit letter not a cluster
that's going to parallel it's all those
tests and tell me if it's going to pass
before I committed them and then what
you're seeing here afterwards is the
stuff that is actually committed as a
group together so we've got four people
integrating their code together and then
the tests are running again so deadline
is saying in this case all four people
who are in the deploy actually there's
more people in the play - you're not
seen but everybody who's in the white
has run try recently which is was
previously published with sneak stuff in
I'm just going to jump in here so this
gives us a little bit more validation
that the people who you're in the train
will are also looking out for you
they're doing their their part if if
let's say Adrian did not run try and
didn't know that his tests were passing
before committing they would call them
out here and surprisingly that's a
really effective way of getting you know
half bots make fun of people instead of
humans really effective for instilling
certain parts of your culture so jenkins
says princess pillows success so now
we're on our pre prod environment the
test only ran and
energy two minutes is their difference I
press the drum functional testing there
but here of the actually know the unit
test is again with the user names
getting status so we're still only at
eight minutes and we're onto our
pre-production environment with only one
more way to go to get to Prague so now
again here's here's Chris saying I'm
gonna join the next cue or whichever one
you want to put me into and these guys
are now saying my stuff is checked out
and it's good to go and push bot jumps
in here and announces that in in other
channels in our big channel I deploy is
going to princess deployed backrest and
there's a similar thing
so there's actually because you've got
the staff deploy and config deployed for
doing those the separate channels and
you can do those in parallel as well but
we have this cross-traffic announcing
that something has changed on our
configs so that if something goes wrong
with the people who are doing this
deploy they have a heads up nano that
that was that there was another recent
change into production that happened and
now Adrian is said that he's good
and we're spot checks back and says ok
everybody is ready now you know check
Jenkins so he asked Jenkins for status
Jenkins says here's your last bill okay
I'm gonna ask you again for status on
princess here's the last bill for
princess
talking to pods and then we have our
this is the button that is in deploy
mater right above the button really
clearly is the hash the shah's that are
they're changing when you go into
production high visibility throughout
the entire the entire system
so now adrian has pushed the button def
blotting channel is saying adrian push
the button confirming that this happened
again cross traffic now it's chef
anybody is chef for configuration
or puppet or any of those right so what
we found a little while ago was those
systems will run to and inject surprises
information and people who are deploying
code will get surprised because they
think that they just screwed something
up so we stuck that into the deploy
channel too so anything that's changing
in production we try to make sure is
serviced here now our bots are popping
back up again starting built out for
prod the park productions deployment
happens your code is live so now the
code is available in FC comm here's a
link to our dashboards where you want to
look at metrics that we're trending over
time and see if anything has has tipped
up or down here's a here's a message
down here the Deaf body's saying here's
the committers in the above the fuch
there's actually seven or eight in here
whereas there were only four people
McCoy and what happened was that we have
a couple of people who have essentially
new code like a brand new command new
say like class file or CSS file that's
not linked to anything on the site but
they're just committing into the
codebase they've got some tests code
that is not live to production and users
once yet and so we allow them to just
sneak stuff in dark without having to be
active in the deploy and this is like
many things it's a judgment concern we
get burned by education now the bill for
production is only 42 seconds it's it's
passed basically some smoke tests and
things like that to make sure they're
all configured in the right place and if
everything is working and then push back
again notifying everything is passed so
then it's a chance for I've mentioned
this already right so the link to the
graphs we have a dashboard and number
dashboards but this is part of his
appointment dashboard that we use so
there's like one thing that everybody
can look at the same business metrics
the same app metrics the same networking
system metrics
it's about 73 graphs on the same page
basically scroll through it and look for
something that's that's a mess and what
you'll see is a bunch of these vertical
lines on here so all these vertical
lines indicate that something was
deployed to production and what you're
looking for is something like here where
this is this trend line for redirects
that are happening on the site and some
config deploy losses are contigs Reds
our app app code so it can think play
happens and you've dropped the redirects
and that was because in this particular
case were changing the way that we're
doing the SSL redirects in the process
of rolling out SSL through the entire
site so that was a particular that have
to do with changing some of that some
can fix that manage that but generally
these are things like registration of
the site logins checkouts so now we're
13 minutes in and we've got code running
in production with production traffic we
can see all the people who have deployed
everybody starts checking in and saying
my stuff is good my stuff is good myself
and my stuff is good at this point which
might ask for status again on prog
Jenkins responds and says everything's
done
diedring who is driving now confirms
we're done with the push and push bot
says yeah who's next in the queue you're
up so now Kevin is getting a
notification at the top of this screen
that says it's your turn to deploy and
then everything goes on so this
particular app deployed 15 minutes we
had four people actually running the
deployment so actively engaged
what's happening eight people were
committing code and then you saw like
cross traffic in there as well from a
couple of other systems and like I said
this is this is a four year effort
suddenly we make changes over time in
this we figured out the optimal hue size
we really work towards normalizing
communication we've got really good
visibility of all the things that are
changing and that has added over time we
didn't we didn't have all those links to
dashboards and we didn't have his
rigorous a dashboard early on and then
the awesome thing about this is that
when something does go wrong we have a
post-mortem got this great Journal of
people actually talking about what they
were doing they can go back to and they
can remember okay yeah that's what I was
doing then this is what I said and if
something was going wrong you might see
Kevin say oh I've noticed something too
mobile checkout scrap right and then you
can turn back to what actually happened
along with all the dips and all the
dashboards and things like that if
something does go wrong man that's
double just causes the push to stop
until we get it solved we work the
people work the issue with the people
who are in push and then there's another
channel for sis ops where all our
operations team is hanging out we'll get
them involved and so there's always
people available to help diagnose and
fix issues that happen in production
especially if they deploy related if we
ever have to do like an off hours push
to resolve something which is usually
limited buddy yep so we'll make sure
that like I'm gonna call Mike or
somebody else and and get him to ride
along with me and sanity check
everything I'm about to do punchline is
that this works on a great big site we
did 1.3 billion in sales last year and
people used to say like yeah
they would work for about three people
we think it does a little better than
that but this has to run up over time
and said this is our deployment rate
over four years this is back in 2010 and
you can see not that many deploy is
happening every single day so this took
us some time to get to the red is
architecture poised the plays these are
the others are at the twenty so in
essence what happened if you stack
pieces this is actually way up here in
terms of the arrows who works in
commerce
these are Monday and like to be
following the great thing about this
system that we've learned is because we
do it all the time we have really high
confidence and we're making very small
changes all the time we have good
validation tools and good exercising of
the client so we feel confident that if
something goes wrong or if we have to
make changes during the height shopping
season we have the confidence to be
pushing otherwise we have penalties and
this would be a flat line here for about
three or four weeks and that saved us a
good number of times first holiday
season I was here we had to do like a
major search algorithm changing on day
one which was scary so this is a part of
a bigger talk but there a few takeaways
probably gathered from it
we took this really slow as we built it
up the iterator governed over time there
was always a way to go back from what we
were doing we didn't like doing this
felt too fast we could always revert and
go back to something else we're probably
not going to do what we did if you
wanted to do something like this go roll
yourself we saw a bunch of ideas from
different places
but these but what you saw was how we've
implemented ourselves yeah so what
happens if the QA tests fail or any of
the tests fail it's it's Gemma Culkin in
cube so it's there's nothing that is by
process or by automation look at what
happened
I take generally like it's pretty clear
this code like what happened
oftentimes somebody will step up and say
well I had something in there that are
looking ahead percent sure oh there's
some times like you and I might commit
at the same time we've got something
that actually does to each other and so
you go you go into Jenkins I know who's
failing you can identify it quickly and
understand what it is they can they can
put a package up quickly and again these
are these are pretty small because we're
deploying a lot we have very small
change so so it's easier to look at the
change that we generally identify what's
going on versus like weeks and weeks ago
the point at some point if you can't
somebody over burglar code and then the
play will go on so you just sort of like
figure it out and everybody like there's
there's a well understood aspect of it
which is we need to keep this moving
pretty rapidly because there's people
behind you waiting to go and so people
learning to jump out of the way and just
say like you know see results
to say goodbye I know the war next that
is it yeah so is it is it mandatory for
everybody who's been in to identify that
good or done or any of those status
checks actually that's right that was
kind of like anybody who is in the push
channel who is deploying something that
they feel is related to active code in
some way I know I mentioned that there
were there were four people you saw who
were regular check regularly checking in
but there were eight people total so the
other four we're committing code that
that they knew was whether it was
cordoned off from production they
weren't concerned about that so they are
not was they they are not registered in
with push Bob they don't know tell
pushpot that their code is good so it's
only the people who are given in the
proper thing yes dark join right and so
if you if you were to say like I'm gonna
join this the point when you get in
there as you go through the entire
process he keeps asking you to do that
so it prevents you from from joining and
then like you know two hours later if
things were going really slow what can
happen is if you have a whole word or
something goes around the production you
can get a big stack of people and you
know somebody ditches off for bit or
like gets called into a meeting or
something like that
the group will identify pretty quickly
if that person is still present and if
not they'll kick them out of it q
progress this deployment is very
dependent upon the quality of the
testing how do you maintain quality of
your tests
in other words do you have metrics for
Coke operational light what prevents
somebody for just cutting corners and
say yeah this is another test you can do
that do it so the question is if we're
relying on quality and community
continuous deployment have we even
measure that and validate that so I'm
going back to code view like teams will
wants to do a certain degree of
confidence within their chain sets not
every change that is going to have code
testicle along with them
each team or and just some degree down
the individuals will decide how much
coverage they want to have we don't need
stitute a specific percentage coverage
or anything like that what we shoot for
is that everybody on the team like very
much the same way that we give you a
thority order to deploy this we also
push the judgment of how much testing is
right to build confidence for you and
your change that as well as that when
somebody else comes along which will
happen in the future then they're not
going to get surprised and like make
something like subtle change like tip
off something that's like a gonna break
all your business logic so it is a
judgment call for us okay but in
particularly corner pieces and inch
cases that not happen except for and
once
you may not you know see the results of
that if it failing badly in the field
you know I'm told many things even weeks
later
that'll be hundreds upon hundreds of the
ploys later now it's far to associate
that failure with what caused the
failure well well you end up in more
time into the testing into the coverage
and what have you and then it's no big
bang integration than the continuous
integration yeah we what we having to
prefer the continuous integration aspect
and the police that is not as heavily
focused on in this talk is those a
sports began that measure user behavior
and what will frequently happen is will
run into something that we didn't think
to us or maybe just blatantly didn't
test but oftentimes it is you know this
this particular case is a total family
house we don't think anybody's ever
gonna trip it into it we're not going to
test that we don't think it's out that
big a risk we deploy it and then like
you know probably go we do rely heavily
on our ability to detect those problems
quickly and to revert them or solvent
quickly as opposed to having frankly
before we started doing this we have
deployment processes that were like six
to twelve hours long and these weeks of
code and in one batch so we're moving to
get really really far away to enable our
team to move very very very rapidly even
if you know we know that we're going to
trip up things that are better
we want to be able to detect those
really quickly in solving really quickly
yes so if you guys do rolling
deployments exactly how do you handle
getting your new deployments into the
load balancer and directs traffic
towards it and is there any performance
degradation associated okay how do we do
deployments operational standpoint so
much of our our app code for SEO is bhp
largely arcing scripts there's a there
is a post on our engineering blog which
is called Cody's crowd which details
some few the real intricacies we've had
with that which is that we use the OP
caption PHP and what will happen with
that by default is the files on the
server and the I knows will get cached
for them and so we have it like write an
extension that will look at the real
amount of the files and we employed to
separate two separate directories so
we've got a one and that's live and then
we were playing to a dark directory and
then to a similarly switch and so you
have to make sure that the same link is
not is not cached but that you're
actually looking at windows that's for
our main app code so basically we can
just arcing right into U star sync in
the live directories and because it was
so quick it you know you don't really
have anything that picks up in terms of
arrows in our searched here we do we
used to do rolling deploys but we found
good bit of stress and one of the
engineers own sake reason so this was a
play essentially walk with peril felt
like he was constantly like dealing with
you know I have deployed thing and then
having
back out so what we've done is we've set
up two clusters of the searched here we
only have one car actually there's three
because we also have an experimental
cluster will employ two and more like a
little valve some traffic on to it to do
to do testing that way and that's on the
JVM so we have like we have like on this
live and then balanced traffic over to
the other one when we're doing deploys
or deploying the code yet already run
tests every pre-warm the caches pre-warm
search and then start moving traffic
over to and the way we do the traffic
moving is through the config files in
the application code and not through a
little balancer okay and you also crying
the interpreted side of the peach um I
know there's a little bit of latency
right the first time you hit any
interpreted language I think that one of
the things we get away with is that
there's there aren't that many files
changing so a good number of them are
certain - the other thing is use this
Marti templating language if any visible
Earth out and the two translations into
a number of different languages so you
end up with if we did not we pre compute
all the templates and so they are ready
to go and they were in pure PHP like I'm
ready I cover deploying them instead of
like smarty that's compiled at runtime
and encash the runtime as well and
that's a that's a pretty expensive
process for us
our new developers intimidated by -
you're teaming up for a great question
I don't I don't think so one of the
reasons why we do this is because we
think that it empowers individual teams
to move very very rapidly and one of the
stories I really like about this is that
the first engineer on my team who went
through the plumbing on the very first
day within this first week he had
deployed seven times four bucks on the
cycle and I thought he was the maniac
and I said you know what is going on
like I thought you might do this once or
twice this week we've done it seven
times and said well I just came from a
company where I wrote for never saw the
[Music]
Wii so we thought about that because you
get surprised by the things that go
wrong and by having humans involved it
means we always have a have a group of
Engineers who are thinking about
deploying to production and
going on interaction this side effect of
having them alone that is that they're
essentially a small asking on call for
the period of time that they're in the
planet so they're always available to
respond to their own problems yes you
people out to what mini Gritty first
what what last question okay that's very
good so quick and greedy and then I kind
of a big picture question do you have an
SLA on how long this is a place loud
laugh yeah I've allowed to allow you
said five minutes for the test what does
a playable so we don't have an SLA for
the entire process of the whole we break
it down to the pieces that we can
control through like software I can't
really control somebody from getting up
from their seats and walking away and
that's where being involved with your
peers you get pressure from people like
you there's an expectation that you're
involved and there's you know you've had
to wait behind other people unemployed
people are waiting behind you like you
learn pretty quickly that you want to
move quickly so yeah we don't really
enforce the specific SLA on that whole
thing what we can do is keep forcing the
we keep looking at the pieces this like
I said we've iterated on this over time
and we keep iterating on things that
will make it faster for us to get code
from for firstnet to deploy and also to
identify issues that happen in
deployments as well so like well
status checks all the links deaths test
results of links the gifts that happen
all this the run log things like that
have helped us identify issues quickly
because if you looked at the histogram
of how long each diploid took we have a
lot that are only about like you know 11
to 16 you're seven minutes and then you
have a bunch that like go out much much
further and there's some cases where you
have a deploy and you might spend three
hours where something goes wrong but it
may not even be related to the stuff
you're applying to time where maybe the
fundamental supplies and what you're
deploying like that was no the big
picture question is what does our
industry look like when this is a
product that any team can drop in what
does it look like when anybody can drop
this in yeah what does what does our
industry look like before that can
happen always have to look like before
that can happen that's a better question
so I think that important aspect of this
is comes back to DevOps and and also a
blameless culture we push because of
this because of the way this all works
we push judgment out to all the
individuals on the team which means that
for me if we have a problem with this
system where something like there's a
rogue element or like this turns into
the disaster really caused by humans
I don't think of that as a recruiting
error like that we failed to hire the
right people or that we failed to train
them in the right ways and instill a
culture where now for each other we're
all trying
do the best effort and we're going to
use our best judgment along the way and
there is something to be said about like
where the industry needs to be I think
you need to have the entire industry
feel that way to which I don't think is
true
[Applause]